greetings and welcome back to our
continuing series about how to optimize
your bigquery spans today we'll be
talking about how you can use bigquery
storage more effectively and make sure
that you're getting both the best
performance and price for that
performance
as a reminder
bigquery architecture is composed of two
parts first we have our fully separated
storage and compute layers so what that
really means is that for all the data
that we store we only use the compute
when we need it this allows us to do
things like store materializations of
different queries at a relatively low
cost while keeping our compute spun down
all this traverses are petabit network
for the most and best cost optimization
and price for performance
let's start digging into the storage
layer today to understand its features
and then how we can best optimize it
first from a building perspective it's
important to note that there are two
options for how to build you can use
both The Logical model or the physical
model
and The Logical model your build for The
Logical representation of a table or
data sets and tables within the data set
this includes things like a logical
representation of an integer field
in this model things like time travel
are included so you're not paying
additional for additional storage in in
this model outside of what the logical
table representation is
in the physical model
you pay for all physical storage of the
of the data and the related assets
including things like the data that's
actually stored for time travel
this option is usually used if you have
data that compresses well and typically
users see a little bit of a benefit from
using this from a cost perspective
next thing to note in this is how you
can use time travel to better configure
how much data you actually store over
Time time travel is configurable between
two and seven days what this means is
that we will store snapshots of all of
your data between the two and seven day
window so if you needed to go back and
say restore data from six days ago if
you had a time travel window of seven
days you would be able to do that
the incremental storage in this is
billed in the physical model but not in
The Logical model
next let's talk about all the different
types of things that are actually
denoted in table storage first the
standard things like tables snapshots
and materialized views are actually
billed based on the bytes that are
actually consumed or The Logical bytes
consumed by those resources we don't
bill for things like cash query results
or when storage is consumed by things
like external tables where the building
is actually performed by the objects or
the data resides them
all right so let's talk about how we can
optimize these different storage
Concepts and really make things best for
you is the developer or the
administrator in this process
first things to consider is using table
snapshots this lets you create copies of
tables without actually having to
physically copy the data into a new
table for that in this example we can
see that we have a base table where
we've created a snapshot and we're not
actually building for the snapshot until
we have changes to the base table that
then constitute storage from a different
block
here you can see that the only things
that we're building for are the new and
change pieces of the data set or the
Deltas from the snapshot table to the
base table
this is very similar for another concept
called table clones
clones also allow us to snapshot a table
at a specific point in time and then
only the base table in the Clone are
billed for the incremental or change
data in each of those models
another way to consider getting the best
performance out of your storage and also
your compute is to consider using
partitions and clustering as a part of
your storage strategy
as a quick reminder partitioning and
clustering work very similarly but
partitioning gives you an additional
benefit that you can use something
called active or long-term storage to
get different benefits from your data
and the act of her long-term pricing
model what happens is if a partition or
a table does not get modified in 90 days
or greater will actually give you a 50
discount on the storage of that object
here you can see an equation example
that once the 90-day window has been
reached and there's been no inserts
updates or deletes against that table we
shifted over to the long-term model and
this does not have any difference in
performance durability or availability
of that data any select queries will
continue to work just as they were in
the past
note that if you change the table let's
say you have to add additional data once
it's it's in long term it will
automatically flip back to active and
there's no additional maintenance you
need to perform as a developer in that
last thing to consider is thinking about
how you can use time to live on
different assets we allow you to
configure time to live on any table and
what this essentially means is that you
can Auto expire tables out or partitions
out based on some time to live value
this makes it easy so you don't have to
continuously monitor your different
tables or take care of different data
within those tables and let the system
work for you
we hope that you've enjoyed this quick
demonstration and overview of how you
can use bigquery storage and optimize
different components of storage for your
use cases happy querying